[music]
>> Can you do this in one minute?
Inshallah. Inshallah.
>> If Allah helps me. Allah helps you. So,
let's see if Allah is going to help you
or not.
Surah Fatiha, chapter number one, the
opening. Surah Baqarah, chapter number
two, the cow. Surah Al Imran, chapter
number three, the family of Imran. Surah
Nisa, chapter number four, the women.
Surah Ma'ida, chapter number five, the
table spread. Surah An'am, chapter
number six, the cattle. Surah A'raf,
chapter number seven, the heights. Surah
Anfal, chapter number eight, the spoils
of war. Surah Tawbah, chapter number
nine, the repentance. Surah Yunus,
chapter number 10, Prophet Jonah. Surah
Hud, chapter number 11, Prophet Hud.
Surah Surah Yusuf, chapter number 12,
Prophet Joseph. Surah Ra'd, chapter
number 13, the thunder. Surah
Ibrahim, chapter number 14, Prophet
Ibrahim. Surah Hijr, chapter number 15,
the rocky tract. Surah Nahl, chapter
number 16, the bee. Surah Isra, chapter
number 17, the night journey. Surah
Kahf, chapter number 18, the cave. Surah
Maryam, chapter number 19, Mary. Surah
Taha, chapter number 20,
number 22, the pilgrimage. Surah
Mu'minun, chapter number 23, the
believers.
chapter number 23, the believers. Surah
35 seconds, 40 seconds.
40 seconds.
Who did not time? Who did not time him,
raise your hand.
Would anyone like to guess what was his
timing?
Was it less than one minute or more than
one minute?
Less. How less?
Takbir!
You weren't confident that you could do
it in less than one minute, correct?
If you have done your homework well,
and learned the other style,
but if you know it well in any style,
your speed will go down,
but not drastically.
If I tell him to say in his style, he'll
be faster, I know that.
But if you know your work very well,
it will go down, but not drastically. If
I know my speed in one particular style,
and I know that I know my speed in one
particular style, and I know that I can
go crisscross and all,
I was
inshallah confident you could do much
less,
because I know his timing of normal
style that he doesn't.
I did not know which style he did
because I had heard that he's fast.
So, now a benchmark has been laid.
Normally, it's not good to have good
competitors, so that your benchmark
becomes
46 seconds,
first 25 surahs.
Multiply by
four and a half, approximately,
you get how much?
How much?
207 seconds.
Less than that.
Three
minutes and how many seconds?
Three minutes 27 seconds, approximately.
What were your
I know it's I think so.
Between 2.30 and 40.
He at present is the record holder
in the school.
Before that was brother Kaleem. Brother
Kaleem, what was your record?
Three minutes 48 seconds.
Don't ask me my record, huh? I stopped
competing. I have become
>> [laughter]
>> two minutes,
how many seconds?
48. And now it's gone to three minutes.
seven seconds. Just a
If you multiply, it's okay. One minute
four seconds, multiply by four and a
half, become four and a half minutes.
Four
four and a half minutes. Four and a half
two minutes.
I did my calculation. I thought
inshallah.
I know that he has not practiced, but
because I
But
never be overconfident.
Being confident is good. Never be
overconfident.
And you when asked, who knows all 114,
three people raised their hands. My
memory is good.
One was brother Sabu, one was brother
Iman, and Farik. Inshallah, time will
come where we'll come to know who's
what.
Inshallah. Arsh.
Good.
But since you had done before,
it is fair.
Fair because
fair.
Okay. Let's give it a try. Say it in
your style.
How much do you think you'll take? Had
each one minute how many seconds?
Kaleem.
What was his speed before? One minute 11
seconds.
11 seconds. Okay, now I'm giving you one
more chance. In your style.
Okay? Do it less than one minute.
In your style. Okay? Start.
Chapter number one, Surah Fatiha, the
opening. Chapter number two, Surah
Baqarah, the house of the cow. Chapter
number three, Surah Al Imran, family of
Imran. Chapter number four, Surah Nisa,
the women. Chapter number five, Surah
Ma'ida, the table spread. Chapter number
six, Surah An'am, the cattle. Chapter
number seven, Surah A'raf, the heights.
Chapter number eight, Surah Anfal, the
spoils of war. Chapter number nine,
Surah Tawbah, the repentance. Chapter
number 10, Surah Yunus, Prophet Jonah.
Chapter number 10, Surah Hud, chapter
number 11, Surah Yusuf, Prophet Chapter
number 11, Surah Hud, Prophet Hud.
Chapter number 12, Surah Yusuf, Prophet
Joseph. Chapter number 13, Surah Ra'd,
the thunder. Chapter number 14, Surah
Ibrahim, Prophet Ibrahim. Chapter number
15, Surah Hijr, the rocky tract. Chapter
number 16, Surah Nahl. Surah Isra, the
night journey. Chapter number 18, Surah
Nahl. Chapter number 16, Surah Nahl, the
cave. Surah
Chapter number 16, Surah Nahl, the bee.
Chapter number 17, Surah Isra, the night
journey. Chapter number 18, Surah Kahf,
the cave. Chapter number 19, Surah
Maryam, Mary. Chapter number 20, Surah
Taha, Surah Taha. Chapter number 21,
Surah Anbiya, the prophets. Chapter
number 22, Surah Hajj, the pilgrimage.
Chapter number 23, Mu'minun, the
believers. Chapter number 24, Surah Nur,
the light. Chapter number 25, Surah
Furqan, the criterion.
Takbir!
What do you think was his score?
41 seconds. Good.
41 seconds, multiply by four and a half,
180.
Three minutes.
Good.
Go and practice.
Any style. Fine, the style has changed.
If you're good,
even changing the style to 42, it was
42, no?
His
No, no. In the second style.
41. That means
you had spent 30 seconds more. With 75%
more time.
You'd like to try in your style?
Huh?
Okay. Let's
see his style.
Chapter number one, Surah Fatiha, the
opening. Chapter number two, Surah
Baqarah, the house of the cow. Chapter
number three, Surah Al Imran, the family
of Imran. Chapter number four, Surah
Nisa, the women. Chapter number five,
Surah Ma'ida, the table spread. Chapter
number six, Surah An'am, the cattle.
Chapter number seven, Surah A'raf, the
heights. Chapter number eight, Surah
Anfal, the spoils of war. Chapter number
nine, Surah Tawbah, the repentance.
Chapter number 10, Surah Yunus, Prophet
Jonah. Chapter number 11, Surah Hud,
Prophet Hud. Chapter number 12, Surah
Yusuf, Prophet Joseph. Chapter number
13, Surah Ra'd, the thunder. Chapter
number 14, Surah Ibrahim, Prophet
Ibrahim. Chapter number 15, Surah Hijr,
the rocky tract. Chapter number 16,
Surah Nahl, the bee. Chapter number 17,
Surah Isra, the night journey. Chapter
number 18, Surah Taha. Chapter number
21, Surah Anbiya, the prophets. Chapter
number 22, Surah Hajj, the pilgrimage.
Chapter number 23, Mu'minun, the
believers. Chapter number 24, Surah Nur,
the light. Chapter number 25, Surah
Furqan, Masha Allah. Takbir!
Takbir!
What was his score?
26 seconds.
That is the Indian bullet train, not
Japanese.
>> [laughter]
>> Huh?
You know India
has told Japan to build bullet train. Do
you know that?
8 billion dollars project.
So, we have Indian bullet train now.
Alhamdulillah.
Inshallah.
If Farik can do,
even you can do. Right or wrong?
You can do it or not? Yes, brother
Ibrahim.
You are from UK, so the UK train should
be faster. The tube.
Yes or no?
>> [laughter]
>> No?
No, the Indian trains are slower.
>> [snorts]
>> The Indian trains are slower than the
tubes.
Okay. Huh? The tube is always delayed.
The tube is delayed. They're delayed
constantly. You know the Indian trains,
masha Allah, in Bombay, Bombay is
supposed to be
the best in commuting.
In terms of, you know, Bombay has a
population of more than 25 million. It's
the third largest city in the world
populated. More than 10 million people
travel daily
in the Bombay trains, masha Allah. They
have to be on time. And it's known for
being on time. Alhamdulillah. And
compared to the number of people that
travel, I actually did not want
Arsh or Farik to
do it. But because they said they are
not sure, I did it.
To make them realize that they can do
it. Otherwise, my intention wasn't
because they should not
come in the picture now.
Sometimes it's good, sometimes it is
bad. For those who like competition,
it's good. They try harder. Those who
don't like competition, oh, forget it.
Not too much.
Depending on good and bad also.
For them, they have to break their
records.
So, inshallah, you already have a target
set.
Who can improve Farik? Who would like to
try?
You can try.
>> You can try.
Sorry?
In your style. You will say.
Okay, try. Okay.
Let's tell him also to try. Okay. Tell
him.
Tell him. Then competition.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah.
Allah.